most of all daughter of ursula uma
brings
all the sass we know and love from her
mom ursula
but the descendants movies left us with
some big unanswered questions
like who's uma's dad and why hasn't his
identity been revealed already uma might
have asked
what's my name in the descendants 2 but
the question we want her to ask in
descendants 4
is who's my dad we learned all about
mal's dad hades in d3 so it makes sense
that uma's dad could play a big part in
d4
we're going deep to figure out who he is
and what role he could play in the
fourth installment of the wicked
franchise
we've lined up three possible candidates
two are descendants villains we've
already met
and the other is a pirates of the
caribbean legend
let's go that's my name
as captain of the pirate crew uma's a
powerful leader
and a formidable enemy so her dad must
be like that too
her mom is certainly rotten to the core
like the other vks
uma has just one parent present in her
life and that's the sea witch from the
little mermaid
we never get to see ursula fully only
getting a flash of her tentacles
but we do get to hear her shouting at
her daughter
these dishes ain't gonna wash themselves
whoopi goldberg provides the voice of
ursula don't you wish we could actually
see her properly
whoopi would make an awesome sea witch
it looks like ursula in the descendants
universe still has a similar appearance
to the original character in the little
mermaid movie
we see a picture of the top of her head
in the sign for her restaurant
ursula's fish and chips where uma works
it's clear that ursula is not a kind and
attentive mother which is no surprise
as none of the villain parents are
loving characters in the novels by
melissa de la cruz we learned that
ursula likes to stay home
and watch soap operas uma tells ben that
her mom doesn't care for her
unless she needs somebody for the night
shift at the fish and chip shop
but what about uma's dad we aren't given
any clue as to who he is this isn't a
big surprise
as we don't get to learn a lot about the
other vk's absent parents either
apart from mal that is who reunites with
her father in the third movie you
abandoned me when i was a baby
no no i left your mother
and that could be the reason why uma and
her dad will take the lead in
descendants 4.
mal's story has always been at the heart
of the descendants movies
now she's found her prince reconnected
with her dad and got her happy ending
her story feels complete but uma's story
doesn't
so it makes sense that the fourth film
will move away from a focus on mal
and on to another vk umo would be the
perfect person to take
center stage she's a complex character
and like the other vks
she's got a more interesting backstory
than most of the aks
her upbringing on the isle of the lost
was difficult her relationship with her
mom
is complicated and she doesn't seem to
have a father figure in her life
she hasn't found her bae yet or her
place she's a villain turned good
just like mal but she's a bit behind mal
in terms of getting resolutions
uma goes on quite the journey in the
third movie helping mal to defeat
queen of mean audrey we're stronger
together
stronger together i'm right here now and
so it looks like disney has set it up
for d4 to follow uma
as she finds her dad and we have the
perfect villain in mind for that
character
those tentacles are a big clue but
before we get on to octopus face
let's stay inside the descendants
universe with a potential father that
could cause a big stir
oh you shouldn't have come here uma's
dad could be mal's dad hades
what's the major evidence for this
theory there seems to be a special link
between hades ember and ursula's
nautilus shell necklace
when mal and uma come together at the
end of d3 it's the combined power of the
ember and the necklace that defeats
audrey
is that because ursula and hades share a
special bond
and uma is the result of their unity
uma's turquoise color scheme is close to
hades and mao's blue color scheme after
all
wouldn't it be fascinating if that was
the case and uma and mal were
half-sisters
these girls have a complicated
relationship just like sisters
some would argue uma's beef with mao
fuels the plot of the second film
we loved getting a glimpse of their
childhood squabbles discovering that
mal's name calling caused a massive rift
between the former bffs as
gil points out she called her shrimpy
and the name just kind of
stuck when they arm wrestle mal taunts
uma with the nickname again
and you can slap a pirate hat on but
you're still shrimpy the final piece of
evidence is that uma and hades form an
alliance in melissa de la cruz's book
escape from the isle of the lost they
plot to defeat mal
bring down the barrier and escape the
isle that's not how it played out in the
movie of course but it's an interesting
side note
did hades help uma because she's his
secret daughter
but there's a flaw in this theory which
relates to ursula's family tree
the makers of the little mermaid
revealed that in the original opening
scene which got cut
we learned that ursula the sea witch is
king triton's sister
that means poseidon is ursula's dad and
you know who poseidon's brother is
hades so it's unlikely that ursula and
hades would have gotten together when
they were uncle and niece
right i know i got it i got the concept
there are other plausible theories about
who uma's dad could be within the
descendants universe
a lot of fans have pointed out the
similarities between uma and dr facilier
and there's also a really cool piece of
behind the scenes information
that totally supports the theory of uma
being related to the villain from the
princess and the frog
and that's to do with the series of
animated shorts descendants wicked world
in that tv show dr facilier has a
daughter called freddy
in the first season she was voiced by
chyna ann mclean
who went on to play uma so in the second
season freddy was voiced by lauren
mclean
chyna's sister coincidence many fans
think not
lauren also starred as freddie in wicked
world's live-action neon lights ball
special
so could disney be hinting that two
real-life sisters are playing two
descendants sisters
eagle-eyed fans have also noticed that
freddy has streaks of grey in her hair
and who has gray hair ursula that's who
there's a theory that uma and freddy are
in fact twins but each parent took one
like in the parent trap and there's a
theory that ursula and facilier tried to
create an alliance to become more
powerful on the isle but ended up
falling in love
realizing love makes a villain weak they
parted without telling a soul about
their relationship
the fly in the ointment here is celia
she's dr facilier's daughter in
descendants 3 and she doesn't have that
gray streak in her hair
you make sure you get your cut but
perhaps her mom is some other villain
than ursula
making her half sisters with uma
although both dr facilier and hades are
possibilities
they don't have pirate or octopus links
so we're coming down in favor of a
different villain being uma's father
this bad guy doesn't exist in the
descendants universe yet
but he's the most probable of them all
uma can turn into a casilla
and become half human half octopus just
like her mom
but uma can also walk on land and be
fully human
so that suggests her dad is or was human
and who is a combination of human and
octopus davey jones from pirates of the
caribbean
let's look at all of the evidence he's a
pirate just like uma
and he's a fearsome captain check he was
human but got tentacles
check and check that's enough to
convince many disney fans that davey's
the daddy
there's a legend that davey jones was a
great sailor until he fell in love with
the sea goddess calypso he struck a deal
with her
thinking he could be with her ashore
after 10 years of duty
but he was forsaken by calypso and his
pain and guilt over his actions meant he
locked his heart in that famous chest
he became even more fierce cruel and
brutal
and he became so intertwined with the
squid-like beast
the kraken that his physical appearance
became monstrous
he grew tentacles and claws
let's be honest if ursula was looking
for a powerful ally to create a powerful
child
she'd probably think davey jones was
quite a catch fans have chatted about
this theory as the most plausible
explanation
and it's not surprising that he didn't
stick around to raise umo with ursula
after all his view of romantic
relationships is far from positive
he was always secretly in love with
calypso so he'd have no time for ursula
or their daughter calypso stayed in his
mind right to the end with her name
being his last word
before he came back years later that is
my heart always belong to you
who do you think uma's dad is would you
like her to become the lead character in
the next movie
give this video a thumbs up if you want
disney to make descendants 4 and hit
that subscribe button while you're here
thanks for watching